massive new demonstrations filled the
streets of Hong Kong on the 22nd
anniversary of China taking control of
the former British colony many
anti-government protesters took their
case against Beijing directly to the
centre of government in the territory
and squared off with police there ramie
Inocencio is covering the protests there
in Hong Kong
good morning hundreds of thousands of
protesters hit the streets today in Hong
Kong's annual pro-democracy march and
depending on where you looked it was
both peaceful and violent this is one
way Hongkongers mark their city's return
to China thousands of protesters mostly
young clad in black and with faces
covered assaulted central government
offices for hours they rammed an
entrance to try to get in protestors
right now are trying to break into
legislative council offices they are
almost actually through this glass wall
here they've been using a metal trolley
to break in but on the other side police
are waiting in riot gear and they've
already been sprayed with pepper spray
protesters are angry at the special
administrative regions top politician
Kerry LOM and by extension her Beijing
superiors they've act controversial
changes to extradition law that could
let China render anyone in Hong Kong to
the mainland opaque court system that's
led to the biggest protests the city has
ever seen Hong Kong police said 13
officers were injured and warned them to
stop but some say violence is needed who
have tried it to you the peaceful men
but this unsuccess even to 2 million
people have opted straight this book out
the voice the government did not respond
obligation to do this we are protecting
hundreds of thousands of others turned
out in peace marching in the city's
annual pro-democracy rally while today's
crowds were smaller than prior weeks
protesters vowed to keep fighting until
their leader resigns earlier Monday
morning Hong Kong's embattled leader
Kerry LOM toasts
Hong Kong's return to China a
celebration moved indoors due to rain
Hong Kong's handover events end with a
spectacular fireworks show over Victoria
Harbour but once the dazzle and the
smoke clear the city will still be the
same angry and very divided over its
future for CBS this morning
rainy Inocencio Hong Kong